so obviously now that we've asked about
uh adult cons and normal conventions
how is it from like japanese conventions
like comic cat to
american ones i guess sometimes scared
just watching some cosplayers
getting like overwhelmed by those camera
guys yeah
and they all take a low angle like
sometimes they are
too close like yeah i feel like they're
just taking
photos of pores like you know it just
works yeah right
there's no i've seen some videos and
then it just seems like locusts
you know they kind of like gather around
and they use conventions by the way
and then they they have no respect for
like personal boundaries a lot of the
times especially if someone's cosplaying
yeah i think i saw a video of a college
player uh i think last comic that was
like crying breaking down yeah
it was uh it was the chinese right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
taking pictures underneath and it's like
she's crying what is wrong
with you i swear like just i don't know
like
there are every now and then i see like
in u.s conventions as well like some
camera guys like trying
yeah it's definitely more mentality like
you know they all come together
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like if like
one cockroach is like okay guys it's
safe and then everyone
let's go into the kill oh my god i've
never been to japanese
kamike or an event in cosplay because
you're not allowed to cosplay outside in
japan i heard this oh
okay you actually need to change at the
event like some kind of changing area so
that's why do you know why uh yes they
got some complaints from
neighbor areas wow it's like i was just
taking my dog for a walk and this woman
dressed up in ram just like rocked up
and
i don't like that character that's crazy
how people would complain about that
yeah
not good for the scenery or something
like that you go to like la during ax
and it's literally just like within like
a one kilometer radius yeah
there's a really funny video last ax of
like you know how in la they started
implementing the scooters that are like
kind of like the
yeah yeah the ones that you can just
like pick up and go and then drop off
and it was like it was a video
of a guy just full on saitama from one
point
just cruising down the road
it was just really funny because
everyone was just like did you did you
see that
i love that about uh like yeah yeah just
conventions right just just seeing
random cosplayers just out and about
just saying just go walking into a
chick-fil-a and just seeing 80 percent
of people in cosplay is like some of the
funniest things
there's obviously a lot of problems with
american conventions but like i do think
they are my favorite ones because like
it's such a fun atmosphere and
most people understand that it's like
all right we're having a good time yeah
exactly
that's all just don't make things weird
yeah don't make things weird man if you
see each other in a denny's you know
yeah all right nice yeah exactly i think
especially recently people have
definitely gotten more aware about
checking each other and making sure yeah
it's really they're not acting like an
[ __ ]
anything like that because i remember
before about like five ten years ago
conventions just seemed to be
operating on this other level yeah i
just yeah it was just like
it was basically just exactly right it's
like
was just like an organized orgy
essentially it's like all right
everybody who is cosplaying
in inuyasha's stuff meet at the 10 p.m
in this hotel room that's basically just
all fury cons right
well organized with the butter mess yeah
is that why like i see a lot of cosplay
isn't consent thing
yeah yeah people are touchy you know and
then i i know that there was what was
that thing a while back when people
would like kiss an anime they would
always run up to each other and jump
uh i i never went to conventions during
the glom phase
i saw videos of it i'm like people like
full-on running into each other yeah
yeah yeah this is like man i
i like my personal boundaries a lot of
times you know i like my personal space
and i think with the general culture
shift to being you know a lot more
respectful
as it should be um i think that's just
kind of pushed in all
right yeah um because i think that the
the big difference i heard about
japanese conventions because i haven't
been to comic yet yet
but i've i've heard that people just go
to comiket literally to shop
it's it's it's it's literally you you
don't go for any events you don't go for
the convention itself it's literally you
buy what you need and then you [ __ ] off
yeah it's basically just like
getting heads first on the latest ocean
from
your favorite artist or whatever and i'm
like i respect that
you know i want first dibs on it yeah
and you need to prepare a lot of coins
because they only take cash so yeah yeah
all right
i've never been either but i kind of i
don't want to go to summer comic yet
yeah that sounds like hell i really i've
always wanted to go to winter comic
but the problem is i'm never in japan
when winter
because i usually go to the us like go
back to australia for to go see my
family for christmas right but
i i think winter comic it seems a lot
more fun i mean
summer just seems like somewhere here
just outside
it's just unbearable in japan in general
let alone you go into you have to get
used to it
comes back like every single year like i
said oh it's japan it's just
yeah we live here i'm just dying right
now
i'm so pale like i i was not made for
anything above like 20 celsius right
anything above 20 and i'm like
ac so like i can't handle this this is
horrible i wanted to leave but obviously
we can't leave i mean i can handle the
heat because you know australia gets
really freaking hot this summer but like
where i'm from there's zero humidity and
so it's not the heat that kills me it's
the humidity it's awful it's the fact
that you walk outside and it's
and it feels like you're standing in
front of a heater like the entire thing
you feel disgusted by yourself yeah yeah
it's just like i'm all sticky and
everything's loose
it's like like a metal solid game i just
gotta plan every one of my movements to
make sure i'm always
in cover you know i'm getting to shade
right
where's my box